hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hand simulator now I
think the title of the game explains
everything that we're about to get into
there's um wait this is a game I [ __ ] it
was good click I don't know how to play
this so if I'm gonna be dueling someone
at war Oh
oh my god it's T its that T game how do
I lower Oh with the mouse wheel huh well
I like to grip my gun sidesaddle like
let me just grab one of these bad boys
I hope there's someone on the other side
of this reins that's struggling to get
this bullet into this gun as much as I
is cuz if I hit a in space I ain't Ally
daintily daintily ain't le daintily i
daintily grass i don't even know what
does someone have 5 kills ok wait let's
think about this logically you would
grab a gun with the other hand duh oh
there we go you would grab a gun with
the other hand get out of here hand I
don't want to see you around these parts
again you would grab it kind of not
quite exactly but kind of like this you
would grab with some firm fingers oh
yeah that's a lot a good grip but I'm
gonna I'm gonna just go give myself
credit for when's credits do there we go
I twisted it okay I'm gonna slap the
side just like hey buddy you're doing a
great job there a good job with you but
did their daughter dial Deedle down grab
ok lift lift hey we've got liftoff Hey
prepare to die I mean even though this
obviously is not loaded at all
let's assume that killed you let's just
assume all right no I don't know where
you think you're going gun but can you
you you hi
come on a second here why don't you just
get back on the goddamn table before I
get shot in the [ __ ] face how about
that lift it up lift it up so I got turn
it a little bit over to my other hand ah
so it stays there okay then I'm gonna
point my poker that's what I call this
finger here open up the chamber barrel I
get all pen you stupid revolver piece of
[ __ ] man I think you only win this duel
by just having more patience than the
other guy
oh I can't oh not quite lower it lower
it lower and drag that's what Marquis
likes I wish I didn't say that already
I'm gonna regret that and gift for him
later but okay how about I just slammed
my finger into the hammer until oh well
that did not work either excuse you okay
I've cocked it oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy anybody even over there no I
hear you bird complaining about how bad
I am I don't need that [ __ ] how
about you take some of not that that's
in not what I wanted you to take take
some of my pinkie button what where's my
pinkie button all right you take some of
this because that's the best I can give
you a good old Quarian hello I got to
figure out how to put a bullet in you
which might mean I'm gonna be here
awhile but ooh dainty
got it I seem to be pushing down all the
buttons but apparently it doesn't like
that too much but I've got a nice sock
solid grip okay wait here I've got a
nice I've got a nice solid grip on this
it's a deadly if you know what I mean
maybe
should have done the tutorial maybe
that'd be a good idea you know what I'm
gonna do that I'm gonna get the old hand
simulators tutorial no there's no
tutorial here what is this
hey flip this fling oh oh oh this is
oddly sexual let's lift it up let's oh
wait I'm cranked I cranked it Oh camera
rotation oh there is a person down there
or there was were I guess I can't die
cube there was no point in that before
so hang on let me see if I can get this
snub-nosed [ __ ] I got I like scooch
the douche there we go
get it to the right hand shape I can't
actually bend my wrist so I gotta just
flop all I got everyone do the flop
indeed look at that like a bow loose
like a boost boughs lift it raise it get
it good switch alright so let's see if
there's actually a dude donger here can
you do dong this dude donger you are you
kidding me are you [ __ ] my dork got
it
that's gotta be it oh you sack of [ __ ]
grunting and thrusting well this went
awry open you bastard let me just slap
that on the table there guess why my
okay got it nailed it okay so let's
switch around give it the old switcheroo
I'm gonna look down at you because
you're inferior to me your machine and
I'm gonna figure out how to poke a good
poking angle oh god okay so that's good
that's right that's nice that's his eye
I grab one of these a bad two Boies nope
if I grab one of these a bad - Bowie's
bad boys I got a bad boy okay I'm
assuming this is not gonna go easy in
this one nope you're gonna be a little
too particular no you're right there
you're angled up so good oh that's such
a good angle on that this would be aa
perfect oh I got it I got it I got it
this is the one there's the one
okay whoo all right ah ah oh no don't
dangle out don't dangle out don't dangle
out don't dangle out oh let me give that
old belly slapped ah
pop that bad boy in there clunk I said
clunk ah ha right it's in there now I
gotta pull the hammer back like 15
bajillion times but I think I'm ready
for that one
okay so I think I gotta go switch II
handy okay so long as I don't drop this
son of a [ __ ] or anything like that
that would be I would be hilariously oh
oh that no ami way me too good right
there
okay switch hands yeah we're getting it
we're learning hands is this how hard it
was as a baby to shoot a gun is this
what you guys your experience as a baby
like did you have trouble loading your
revolver
all right let's slam the hammer down no
angle this give the old devil horns
there cuz we're gonna need it I need a
little bit tannic intervention here oh
yeah oh you had that yeah oh okay it's a
downward and a clicky motion okay so I
know this isn't the right one but I'm
gonna try to fire it anyway just because
I need Duke in the hole or are you not
in the hole getting that in that trigger
hole oh I'm gonna assume I hit it I got
no points that means I hit it
yes that means I missed zero that's what
that means let's try the old yield
spinners here so the oh boy oh boy oh
boy my name here bah bah boo
oh my god am
[Applause]
and that spells mark I got it okay but
let's get to what you all were really
here for which is this sweet sweet
there's no way I'm ever gonna get this
to spin am i ah my finger is through
that oh I thought I had scooped it okay
I'm a I got dangling her head ah you
bastard you clumsy piece of poo Oh quite
not quite faked you out oh oh I had it I
was that cast a spell go oh it's a
feisty one
oh it's fidgeting oh wait no do I do I
have it if I let go of my ring finger I
just give myself the old this treatment
because I deserve it
nope what the pink one yeah okay I got
it that's not good
let go of middle okay it's in the palm
of my hand
take it from my palm young grasshopper
this doesn't actually help me any more
than it picking up from the table but
I'm just gonna do it anyway hey ho hey
ho hey ho I got it no God son of a
spinning it was spinning I saw it can
you even grab that thing squeeze harder
than you've ever SQUOZE is that you're
hard to squeeze no that's not your
hardest SQUOZE SQUOZE harder please
disclose with your heart's content and
dire oh that's not squozen oh oh oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh oh okay just
leave it right there
that's perfect switch okay now I'm gonna
give this the old Flicka Roo just gonna
point oh I don't like that okay we're
gonna boink oh it's spinning its
spinning yes oh just graze it like a
wheel whoa I got a g-man
yeah those adequate spin okay so anyway
that is hand simulator thank you
everybody so much for watching I feel
like I wasted my time completely but
maybe you guys didn't so I hope you
enjoyed it so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought of this down in the comments
below and if you want to duel me let me
know that as well thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]